[Music]
Miss USA 2017 is 25 year old Cara
McCullough is 2017 s Miss USA Cara is a
scientist and says her plan is to
inspire children and women to go into
the science fields after her big win
Cara takes over duties from dashana
barber 2016 s Miss USA and a fellow Miss
District of Columbia one of the stories
and one of the things we took away from
your win was you can be smart pretty and
all those things and still be Miss USA
and still keep your femininity but be a
badass and beYOU know be a member of our
military and all of those great things
what's the thing you learn most about
yourself over this past I really learned
that I'm representing such a huge sense
of diversity for women and it's just
diversity in what you do being that
modern-day woman that is just able to
tackle so many things at once but still
not lose that femininity so not lose
that women hood just because we have a
just because you're carrying a rucksack
and a weapon so you know I think that
that's one of the great things about
being Miss USA and being able to
represent the military and pageantry
it's just so the shows that women are at
first on
[Music]
you